avec nous et la buse et émilie nicolas
et christian dufour bonsoir bonsoir je
vais vous faire commenté en dernière
heure / tour de table donc sur les 2
michael kovak espoirs qui dès vendredi
vont se retrouver devant la justice
chinoise après deux ans de détention
hélène je le disais tout à l'heure le
tout du succèdent pour d'un point de vue
d'un accusé en chine est de 1% il ya 99
% chez les le vrai chiffre de
condamnation ça donne froid dans le dos
quand même oui tout à fait et quand même
beaucoup de ces condamnations ne se
soldent par des condamnations à mort il
faut le dire
évidemment c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle que ces procès là en même temps
je me demande si la chine devait
liquider ces deux personnes là elle
perdrait tout son son levier de pression
qui est qu'elle utilise contre le canada
alors je me demande s'il ne se garderont
pas une petite gêne pour pouvoir
continuer à exercer cette pression
politique pour obtenir ce qu'il désire
finalement c'est à dire la libération de
la ressortissante way ml nicolas on suit
ça depuis deux ans évidemment c'est
cousu de fil blanc
cette histoire là les chinois dit ça n'a
rien à voir avec man wenzhou mais on
sait que ça a tout à voir avec ça
effectivement on sait qu'à tout à voir
avec ça puis on sait aussi que depuis
l'élection d'aubry dans cette partie des
dossiers qui ont été discutées en
priorité entre le justin trudeau et d'un
nouveau président américain
donc dans ce contexte le début du procès
france aucune espèce de ce matin dans un
certain sens parce que si la justice
chinoise condamne les deux maillots
savait très difficile ensuite de
négocier quoi que ce soit parce que sans
que la justice chinoise à bout
finalement que c'était c'était quelque
chose de politique donc c'est vraiment
important de surveiller ce qui va se
passer dans les prochains jours ses
programmes en question de vie ou des
noirs comme il ya déjà été dit pour
céder personnes à christian la justice
chinoise que quelques mots ironiques
ce sont des otages en fait depuis deux
ans la chine décédée au chu
kazim c'est extrêmement inquiétant de
voir que la le pays qui de plus en plus
la première puissance mondiale que le
vent dans les voiles respecte à ce point
là pas du tout les principes
élémentaires en fait des sociétés j'irai
civilisé on l'a vu contre we go
collectivement parce que c'est une
tentative en fait des limitations de
deux génocides d'un peuple on le voit
comme des individus maintenant un petit
rappel chez ça va servir à rien mais le
canada paie quand même aussi le prix de
sa naïveté initiale dans ce dossier il
faut peut être rappeler quand on
arrêtait want miles ou parce que trump
se servait nous autres dans le dossier
contre l'iran c'était extrêmement naïf
et deux canadiens otages qui paie le
prix de sa et qui risquent leur vie
littéralement dans les prochains jours
javier ou tout début à christian qu'on a
parlé de ça il ya deux ans presque vous
aviez dit on aurait dû libérer manouane
jouer ne pas et au départ il y avait
beaucoup de gens c'est l'état de droit
ici depuis il ya plusieurs voix qui se
sont élevées dont des juges de la cour
suprême hélène buzzati pour 0 n'aurait
pas dû peut-être faire des exceptions
qui l'a laissée année là ouais j'y avais
tout respect je suis pas certain que ce
soit la bonne démarche et c'est toujours
seul le problème quand on embarque dans
cette logique des otages parce que c'est
effectivement je suis d'accord avec
keith y en at il ce sont ces de michael
des otages c'est que lorsqu'on plis et
ben tous nos ressortissants de vienne se
font peindre une cible dans le dos et
deviennent des otages en puissance alors
je pense que la solution elle passe
davantage par une réponse diplomatique
concertée internationale contre cette
chine qui est effectivement à monter en
puissance s'impose dans le monde et un
poste où sa vision de sa vision des
choses et sa façon de faire de la
politique
et c'est contre ça il faut aller au delà
du cas spécifique des de maicon et et
dire à la chine que elle doit changer si
elle aspire à jouer dans la cour des
dents très bien je vais vous parler de
la hausse salariale
dp des dirigeants d'investissement
québec doit mettre ça de côté
j'en ai beaucoup parlé avec avec gerald
une grande trois questions à air
d'économies dans quelques secondes
il ya des pour ya des cons mais parce
que comme on a ajouté les chinois 12 je
vous parlais des autres sujets cette
offre d'emploi qui émane du sis des
laurentides c'est la presse qui nous
apprenait ce matin pour femmes blanches
et noires mais ça fait sursauter je veux
entendre même guilbaud et des réactions
de l'opposition
aucun bon sens ça aucun bon sens on
s'entend tous là dessus mais la
situation à laquelle vous faites
référence quand même faut se placer
aussi à la place des employés c'est moi
je me mets à la place des employés l'a
d'ailleurs une situation qui était très
difficile pour ce qu'on en sait le quai
difficile parce que le lion un patient
qui ont des troubles par aman des
troubles cognitifs et qui réclament de
se faire soigner toujours par le même
profil de personnes donc j'ai quand même
beaucoup d'empathie pour cette situation
le puits les soignants qui vivent avec
soi puis on cette contrainte le de
devoir s'adapter à une situation
médicale qui est vraiment vraiment pas
facile jamais un établissement dans leur
demander à ce qu'une personne noire une
personne autochtone une personne une
personne d'une certaine religion soit la
personne embauchée et illégale la
discrimination à l'embauché c'est
immoral c'est inacceptable dans une
société démocratique
moi je suis un grand amateur de youtube
puis ça me fait penser à cannes believe
the news today
c'est jacques gaudreau cas une bonne
ligue christian ouais ben je pense qu'on
a deux camps en fait on dit que du
racisme le cas de l'hôpital jeu de
julien dont je voudrais parler un petit
peu parce que il récidive à l'hôpital de
joliette
deux infirmières en fait qu'ils ont un
comportement clairement raciste à
l'égard d'une patiente clairement
honteux aussi à l'égard d'une patience
autochtone et la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'une sanction rapide immédiate très
forte
on ne conduisaient les deux infirmières
et je vois la patiente
c'est le brigitte par contre dans
l'autre dossier moi je trouve pas que
c'est du racisme bien franchement je
trouve que les titres de la presse dix
offres d'emploi pour semble ans
seulement et je m'en tombent à terre
quant aux missions dit on et 2021 c'est
quoi cette affaire le quand on lit
l'article
parce qu'elle est intéressant on apprend
des choses bon on apprend que c'est une
grosse maladresse suite une bourde c'est
clair mais qu'on apprend que dans les
hôpitaux ils doivent composer parfois
avec des patients qui font de la démence
sont désinhibés par rapport à leurs
préjugés à l'égard des des soignants de
couleurs dont ils peuvent les agresser
ils peuvent refuser de se faire soigner
il faut que les hôpitaux compose avec ça
c'est pas du racisme mais ça et la
maladresse évidemment c'est d'avoir
lancé une offre d'emploi pour un emploi
c'est pas dit pour 10 personnes en ont
vu une personne blanche c'est maladroit
c'est une grosse erreur de jugement mais
c'est pas du racisme c'est chaud faut
faire attention pour voir du racisme
partout parce que ça discrédite la lutte
contre les racismes joliette c'est
clairement du racisme et ont mis les
infirmières d'or tant mieux mais
saint-eustache en tout respect moi je
trouve que c'est possible il colle à que
vous en pensez ben quand on regarde
l'histoire la divination d'emplois pour
des motifs racistes au québec
ce qu'on voit c'est que souvent quand il
ya eu de la discrimination ou même
systémique
c'était pour en en disant mais la
clientèle va pas aimer ça c'était le cas
par exemple dans les années 80 quand on
les taxis les chauffeurs de taxi a
essayé ont dû faire la grève parce que
il y avait plusieurs clientèles qui
voulait pas avoir des chauffeurs de taxi
noir puis c'est ce genre ce genre de
situation la vub aussi beaucoup d'amis
et la restauration
quand les employeurs disent on veut pas
engager tels profils de personnes donc
il y avait énormément descrimination
emploi racistes au québec qui ont lieu
avec cette logique donc si cette logique
l'heure on veut pas la reconnaître
comme raciste en fait on va encore d'un
ensemble de décisions qui ont déjà été
prises dans le passé par là comme sont
des droits de la personne du québec
hélène moi moi ça me fait beaucoup
rappelé le débat sur les accommodements
raisonnables que l'on a eus retour à en
2006 2007 qu'est ce qui avait mis le feu
aux poudres c'est qu'on avait appris que
certaines personnes dans leur rapport à
l'état exigeait de ne pas transiger
par exemple des personnes d'un certain
sex donc on voulait pas avoir par
exemple des policières
on voulait pas avoir une femme préposé à
la saaq ou inversement
une femme musulmane en ceintes demandé à
ne pas être traités par un homme et ce
qui avait dérangé les québécois c'est
que le gouvernement au lieu de
désapprouver ce genre de demander
clairement misogyne clairement c'est
discriminatoire les avait endossé en
essayant d'accommoder ses demandes et il
semble qu'on se retrouve un peu dans la
même situation on a ici un patient qui
réclame d'être traité par une personne
blanche et au lieu de dénoncer ce
comportement raciste on le cautionne
d'une certaine manière on descend de
l'accommoder mai mais je suis un peu
d'accord avec avec ce que titien disait
par ailleurs il faut prendre acte du
fait qu'on a à faire un patient si j'ai
bien compris un peu des mains il est
hospitalisé il a droit à des soins
et si on lui imposait le roi de couleurs
oui mais voilà droit christian je
voulais ça par exemple at il eu droit à
tous ses caprices il dit moi je veux que
ça soit que des arbres qui fait de la
démence et des îles et des mâles et dans
l'article on persuade politique ne peut
pas régler ce genre de colloque ya des
gens qui fonda solidité qui ont des
problèmes puisque élections on est dans
la démence
donc il faut gérer ça et une chose que
j'aurais rappeler parce que moi j'ai une
autre part de toujours
ce dynamique négative on dans l'article
la presse aujourd'hui quand même une
très bonne nouvelle
on nous dit que les agences privées
traditionnellement reçoivent des
demandes en fait de gens qui voulaient
maintenant avoir des défendre il voulait
pas être traités par des hommes des
choses comme ça et on note qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de demandes de cet ordre
là ces dernières années qu'on avait
avant faut le dire ces choses là aussi
on n'est pas dans une situation c'est
plus en plus racée c'est toujours du
raciste et moi en tout respect quand tu
dois traiter une personne qui fait de la
démence le faut que tu te sentes on ne
saute pas le choix à moins de la laisser
mourir
il ya une grande différence
émilie nicolas mais quand pensez-vous
entre demander par exemple si une femme
ne veut pas se faire laver par un homme
c'est une grande différence a demandé
qu'une femme devienne la traiter la
soigner que de demander quelqu'un avec
quelle couleur de peau c'est parce que
ça sert avec leurs inhibitions ça leur
enlève leurs inhibitions la démence donc
est ce qu'on voit là leur ticket très
bon là dessus et j'inviterai les
téléspectateurs lisez le la possible
vous allez voir à quel point c'est
complet c'est moi je trouve ces photos
du racisme ok mais en fait c'est parce
que les employeurs aussi une
responsabilité pour protéger leurs
employés donc c'est aussi aussi qu'on
oublie comme dimension là dedans donc
une différence on par exemple lire dans
tous les employés que j'ai je peux
envoyer mon employé dans cette situation
et risque de vivent de la violence
verbale ou même une agression physique
donc je fais ça pour protéger mon
employé c'est d'autre chose que de faire
de la discrimination à l'embauché
carrément et de dire moi je veut
embaucher dépendance gc ca 7
cette limite le cette ligne là que je
sens qu'on ne vient pas toujours quand
on analyse cette nouvelle là ok question
vous avez parlé de l'hôpital de joliette
là il ya eu
vous êtes à votre avis un geste raciste
clair il ya eu sanction claire je vais
en temps des milliers hélène la tuer la
wii est clairement musique selon les
détails qu'on nous en donne et on en a
pas énormément que la maille leurs
gestes répréhensibles ici et il a été
condamné
moi je ça me fait un peu rigoler quand
j'entends les gens dire ah ben voilà
c'est la preuve que qui ce qu'on fait là
n'a pas fonctionné parce que six mois
plus tard après le code zeus et chaque
fois on y est encore écoutez si
effectivement on a affaire à un racisme
systémique telles que tout le monde
semble le dire
eh ben c'est pas si moi qui feront toute
la différence faut quand même
donner le temps aux changements qu'on
essaye de repérer de se faire
mais visiblement ce n'est pas avec une
seule petite formation auprès des
employés qu'on va radicalement changer
les mentalités il faudra revenir à la
charge et revenir encore et encore pour
que peu à peu ce genre de comportement
le disparaissent en tout cas emilie une
grogne comme on dit ça pas niaiser ça
durerait deux jours les infirmiers a été
retiré non effectivement sur ce colloque
est une action rapide puis dans un sens
ça montre qu'il ya eu un choc dont
culturelle dans ce si cela précisément
aussi on sait qui vient d'engager une
personne autochtone pour dans la haute
direction pour aider à faire améliorer
les relations avec avec la communauté
attikamek en particulier ceci dit je
pense que c'est important aussi de
comprendre que l'appui dans la plupart
des cas de discrimination dans les
hôpitaux
ça se répand notamment exprimé de façon
aussi claire il peut avoir par exemple
une personne autochtone qui arrive à
l'urgence puis il faut simplement être
négligée complètement ou là ou peut-être
que l'accolade qu'on l'apprendra pas au
sérieux ou qu'on voit associé par
exemple ces symptômes mais je sais pas
de l'alcoolisme des stéréotypes comme ça
et dans des cas comme ça c'est très
difficile de dire mais voilà c'est dur
assister la personne est renvoyée
immédiatement donc mon souhait pour la
suite des choses c'est qu'on soit
capable d'agir pour régler les cas
explicite tout comme les coop city qui
au final peut faire aussi énormément de
dommages très bien il reste combien de
temps un petit mot au tour de table
j'aurais pas tant de faire entendre
monsieur legault mais vous savez c'est
ce texte qui était à un peu vantard en
disant quelle autre équipe que celle de
monsieur legault aurait pu mieux gérer
la pandémie au québec a été retiré du
sein de la cac
tournée tab rap et de christian ça c'est
l'extrait de lalaye de la cac qui s'y
est ce que c'est une bonne idée d'avoir
retiré
oui parce que c'est un pull jaune à moi
j'ai beaucoup d'indulgence pour la
propagande politique des politiciens
parce que c'est difficile pour eux mais
le problème c'est qu'il semble y croire
à leur propagande
non vraiment on a l'impression que des
gens autour de monsieur legault qui sont
convaincus que ça a été une gestion etc
c'est exceptionnel et monsieur legault
quand il était élu il avait mis en garde
ses députés les avait invités à beaucoup
de modestie et à éviter l'arrogance
surtout après du mouvement mode et si
émilie nicolas modestie effectivement
c'est le monde or depuis aussi ça va
j'espère que ça va être le monde leur
dossier dans le prochain cycle électoral
le problème c'est que si on est déjà en
train de faire les bilans comme étant un
bilan fantastique et puis on va essayer
de l'année l'action là dessus
éventuellement ça crée un problème ou
auront ce repas n'y a pas de faire la
vérité en fait sur ce qui s'est passé
durant la pandémie et ça peut
effectivement qu'il ya un problème à
long terme hélène je vous donne trente
secondes c'est injuste mais je
est-ce que ça commence à la fièvre
continue à monter à 3 pour les élections
où ça baise haut et continue à augmenter
beaucoup c'est là mais ça augmente c'est
encore possible
je veux que les gens sachent comme nous
merci à vous tromper nabeul et messieurs
revoir